was introduced its ion finally took
center stage
[Applause]
now laters on the floor and he'll
continue to improve throughout the rest
of the year
tonight's starting lineups are
deliberate side table did tell us before
the game we might see some zone there is
ion stepping back pulling the trigger
here's a lob the side
put a look at the one jean-bob right now
Dianna's they want cider to get it here
he is
and Colonel parked at Sian gets it back
and finishes ten person just over
Williamson Zion gives it up gets it back
curious again
[Music]
yes it that Siam prepare for
[Applause]
and even though he was called a foul so
right now there a chance we want Sion
from the crowd here and it's certainly
understandable you know the first week
whether by mark all of us were saying
okay is this hitch like the first three
quarters he barely played we didn't
really see what we saw in preseason and
a Duke but man in that three minutes
stretch he took over I would say this as
a fan and as an announcer I'd love to
see him in the ball game